[Musique]
je tends jeu top
bonsoir julietta bonsoir les enfants
jules iota ne put pas laurel tu es trop
pressé de me faire descendre c'est parce
que tes amis d'atteindre nounours voilà
j veu
popopopop bonbons cornichons tu veux
m'apprendre à jouer de la guitare
oui bien sûr
regardes tu la tiens comme ça lui les
états voient l'ananas bonsoir mes amis
de la roulotte voix soit nous tu sais je
vais jouer de l'équipe est plaint pas
preneur ou
je m'assois au mes enfants j'ai des
soucis des soucis mon cher morceau
bonsoir tata oui deux vrais soucis je
suis sans nouvelles des milliards depuis
plusieurs jours mash up
mettez les femmes mais oui c'est
difficile sans télé faire comment tu
n'as pas le téléphone ben non mais je
vais te l'installer c'est très facile il
vous appartenait au père était cher
nounours non alors rtf cher tada vous
êtes très drôle les enfants apportez moi
deux boîtes en fer vide
oui et de la fille seule
voilà les boîtes
merci cornichons
merci nicolas vous allez voir
tu peux rire ma belle
[Musique]
regardez
et voilà est astucieux
merveilleusement ici or rien de plus
facile
je vais parler avec l'angleterre
halo legends hollow
2010 nounours
ou de notes atteignant 13 astucieux quel
pays vous voulez vous
qu'à cela ne tienne
photo j
oui nous lourd wen a noté
ciao
astucieux
mexico mexique du gua akin l'ours
kl halo ambré
buenas noches
chiquito
pas ce soir il est trop tard un plaisant
plus astucieux vous dites dada je dis
qu'il est temps en effet merci morale à
long ou lit
bonne nuit cher nounours bonne nuit
shirt adam melling
bonne nuit les petits
boonen il juge le tas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le viol devant le lol lol lol tu as la
vie est belle patron le fait non pas
cette tête là la halle paul paul bas on
prend le large oui allons-y denis les
petits elle fait bourez
molodoï le poteau
[Musique]
e
on